today on the matt walsh show in honor of
trans day of visibility the biden
administration has made a number of
policy changes including allowing you to
list yourself as the gender of x on your
passport how exactly is that going to
work also backlash grows against
disney's self-professed gay agenda as we
at the daily wire announce our response
to leftism in children's entertainment
and a lesbian couple sues a fertility
clinic for giving them a boy instead of
a girl the experience of giving birth to
a boy was they say like quote rape in
our daily cancellation people with phds
complain about being marginalized when
others fail to address them as doctors
so you know we got to cancel these
people all of that and more today on the
matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
well if you've been listening to my show
for a while you're probably familiar
with one of our top sponsors rock otto
recently my producer mckenna told me
about her own experience shopping with
rock otto and how great it was for her
as a person who knows nothing about cars
i don't remember this conversation
mckenna was carpooling with her
boyfriend during an ice storm and turned
on his windshield wipers before he got
in the car to help get rid of the ice
but with this simple act she destroyed
his windshield wipers and they had to
drive in the rain with wipers that
barely could wipe the rain away during
the drive to work she figured it was
worth checking rockauto.com to see if
they had a replacement option for the
windshield wipers and sure enough she
was able to buy some new windshield
wipers for the car that are made to deal
with ice and for a surprisingly
reasonable price so if you're like
mckenna and you like to write ad copy
about yourself and you need a quick fix
or if you need to do some major repairs
you should check out rockauto.com
once you go to rock auto you can tell
that i was just telling that story from
memory a list will guide you through
every single make and model that you
could possibly imagine all you have to
do is quickly find your car and rock
auto will give you a list of every part
available for your vehicle included with
the with the port descriptions are
photos and specs so you can feel
confident you're choosing the correct
parts so go to rockauto.com for your
auto part needs today and write walsh in
there how did you hear about us box they
know that i'm the one that sent you
that's rockauto.com to shop for your
auto parts today
as you may or may not have heard today
is a sacred holiday called international
trans day of visibility
this is a day set aside to specially
affirm acknowledge recognize celebrate
trans people
and it's good that we have a day like
this because there are not enough days
on the calendar specifically dedicated
to honoring
people who identify as lgbt i mean all
we have right now is international
transgender day of visibility
and also lesbian visibility day april
26th and uh international day against
homophobia transphobia and biphobia may
17th and of course harvey milk day may
22nd
and pansexual and pan romantic
visibility day may 24th and obviously
pride month in june followed by
bisexuality day uh september 23rd and
then obviously bisexual awareness week
september 23rd to september 30th
and national coming out day october 11th
pronouns day october 16th national lgbt
center awareness day october 19th spirit
day october 20th intersex awareness day
october 26th asexual awareness week
october 23rd through the 29th
and transgender day of remembrance
november 20th and pansexual pan-romantic
pride day december 8th
so you see lgbt people clearly aren't
visible enough all they have is an
entire month and a dozen other separate
holidays that's all they got
along with really every other day on the
calendar because no group of people on
earth today or at any other time in
history
have been so specially and obsessively
and incessantly recognized and
celebrated there has never been such a
mismatch between a group's size and the
population and their influence over the
culture it's an influence so extreme
that society itself is being reorganized
as we speak in order to cater to the
demands of lgbt activists every
institution in the country has made lgbt
awareness and activism its primary
priority
major corporations like disney are
willingly alienating 99 of their
customer base for the sake of lgbt
extremism
our very conception of reality itself of
human nature of biology is being
reordered and reshaped at the best of
lgbt activists
and the process isn't done because i
mean it's never done
in fact the white house unveiled today a
whole new list of initiatives to um
coincide with the trans day of
visibility charlotte climber who's a
militant trans activist with the human
rights campaign outlined all of the new
policies in a twitter thread this
morning so i'm going to read some of
this to you it says
the white house and federal agencies put
out a number of wonderful announcements
about trans rights a few hours ago so
i'm so excited to tell you about them
because today should be a day about
trans and non-binary joy
one the state department announced that
starting on april 11th u.s citizens will
be able to select x as a non-binary
gender marker on passports
they are the first federal agency to
codify this inclusive policy applicants
can
already self-select without medical
documentation
two uh tsa announced that they are
updating their body scanners at airport
security to move away from tech that has
led to trans and non-binary travelers
experiencing frequent discrimination
reducing unnecessary and invasive and
humiliating body searches so excited for
this three tsa is also working with
airlines to implement non-binary markers
during the flight booking process
removing gender considerations with
validating traveler info at airport
security including non-binary markers
during tsa precheck enrollment and cbp
trusted traveler
four department of health and human
service services released a new website
that offers resources and guidance for
lgbtq youth and families to counteract
several gop-led state governments
removing such resources from their own
websites in recent months and five the
department of education's office of safe
and supportive schools is expanding
training with more resources to educate
school leaders and communities about the
challenges facing trans and non-binary
youth and their families
and the list goes on climber lays out
actually 13
new transaffirming initiatives from the
white house today and notes that it's
only a partial list but let's focus for
a moment on just the first three items
you'll now be allowed to put your gender
down as x on your passport
now
the whole point of a passport of course
is to provide information about your
physical identity so that governments
can document and keep records of who is
coming and going
that's why we have passports so if
they're going to let you put x as your
gender on your passport because that's
how you feel whatever the hell it means
to feel like an ex
they might as well let you change your
date of birth to better align with your
self-perception i was born on june 18th
1986 but um
sometimes i feel like somebody who was
born on april uh 4th 1991
or you know august 7th 1948.
i feel like that sometimes how does that
feel but just it just feels how i feel
i'm asking any questions about it
why can't i change my passport to
reflect that really if identity is fluid
then
we shouldn't have passports at all i
mean all the passport does at best is
capture my identity on the moment when i
applied for it and took the picture but
no passport can truly encapsulate the
full essence of my ever-evolving being
now you might point out that this
passport change is total insanity for
many reasons
not the least of which being that the
rest of the world has not signed on to
this
your passport as an american is meant to
get you into other countries but most
other countries in the world especially
in the non-western world
do not recognize the gender of x
you're gonna have a lot of trouble
explaining your ex-gender to the customs
agent over in iran or tanzania
has the byte administration taken that
into account
i mean have they coordinated with every
other government in the world to make
sure that this is going to be recognized
well of course not
these are important practical concerns
but important practical concerns have no
weight when stacked up against a trans
person's desire to be affirmed
and as established
all of human society must be reorganized
for that purpose
it's our highest purpose as a
civilization it's our only purpose
that's why we're all here did you know
that
it's just to affirm lgbt people it's
your it's the only reason you exist
now
that explains why all of these changes
are also being made to the airport
screening process now at least the
change is there
if if this actually happens they reduce
the airport strip searches
make the screening process less invasive
etc those are mostly positive
i mean that's assuming that this will be
the case for everybody and not just
trans people uh they're making it less
invasive for everybody if that's the
case that's a big if then i would call
that a positive change but consider the
fact
that travelers at american airports have
been treated like suspected drug
smugglers and terrorists for 20 years i
mean for 20 years just the simple fact
that you want to
get on a delta airlines flight and you
know fly to um uh cincinnati or
something that alone
meant that you are suspected of
terrorism and they're going to treat you
as if they have reasonable suspicion of
a crime so they're going to do all these
searches and everything else
so they've been doing that for 20 years
they've been doing pat-downs on old
ladies in wheelchairs and making kids
remove their shoes in case the you know
the little nine-year-old is sneaking
explosives and his velcro nikes
they've been doing all of this for
multiple decades no matter how much we
complained about it but all it took was
a few trans people feeling uncomfortable
and suddenly the whole system is being
retooled
you know you had an old lady complains
about it and they say shut up granny
but then a trans person complains and
they say oh no i'm so sorry well here
let's just completely change everything
for your sake i'm sorry to have offended
you please forgive us
if that's not privilege and power i
don't know what is
now those in the audience who are a
little bit younger and only became
politically aware a few years ago
or maybe people who are older and still
only became politically aware a few
years ago may be surprised to learn
that lgbt activism at least in the
mainstream had a much different tone as
recently as eight or nine years ago
there have always been the militant
factions and now there are only militant
factions but up until recently
the lgbt rights quote unquote movement
marched under banners that said things
like you know we just want to be left
alone and what two consenting adults do
in their bedrooms doesn't affect you
and we just want tolerance
now the more perceptive among us such as
yours truly uh recognized at the time
that these claims and slogans were
nothing but a cover story
but lots of people took it all at face
value
believing that the activists really just
wanted to live their own lives and peace
and nothing more
those people have been taken by surprise
now shocked to learn that actually what
the activists want
is not to be left alone or to be
tolerated but to have all of society
our laws our institutions our lives
revolve around them
and their desires
and now
everyone is finally learning that fact
but it's a little late in the game
unfortunately
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right so going to uh
back down to florida and the backlash
over the parental rights bill
um with people on the left still just
unable to contain their outrage that
they won't be able to at least in
florida talk to kids at least under the
age of like third grade and younger
about sexuality
um i want to actually start by by
playing a couple clips for you because i
thought
i thought these were interesting here's
um raven simone who is uh
actress
or a what is she a singer i don't know
what she does
oh actress i'm being told okay so raven
simone is an actress and who knows what
and um
she is also on on technology she was on
the today show and on tick tock speaking
out
about the uh don't say gay bill which
people like her invented and doesn't
exist i want you to listen to what she
says because she actually says something
that i kind of agree with listen
i'm going to say this and this is my
thing if there's a don't say gay bill
there should be a don't say straight
bill because it's not fair and there are
multiple kinds of humans in this world
and you are ruining the psyche
the confidence of so many young children
because you are discrediting their
parents the people they love the people
that raise them the people that teach
them the manners when they walk into
that school room so if you're not gonna
honor their family your family shouldn't
be honored either so let's just make it
even slash equal
and no part of that made sense
whatsoever this is a parental rights
bill and somehow it dishonors parents so
now she's concerned about parents
parents are the ones saying i don't want
you talking to my kids about this stuff
that's what parents are saying
so you're dishonoring parents by not
so
as a parent if i send my
six-year-old to public school in florida
i am being dishonored
if my if the if the first grade teacher
doesn't talk to my kid about their
sexuality
i mean think about how confused and
deranged you have to be to
see things that way
but she does say that uh if we're gonna
have a dose don't say gay bill we should
have a don't say straight bill and we
don't have a don't say gay bill but in
this fantasy scenario where we do um
don't say straight fine i'm i'm good
with that
yeah let's not talk about that either
that's that's the point there's no
reason why you should be taught why you
need to sit down with a seven-year-old
in
elementary school and talk about gay
straight anything
any anything sexual related you don't
need to talk about it so absolutely
um yeah i'm on board for that
i don't want you you don't need to teach
a seven-year-old about gayness neither
do you need to sit down and teach him
about straightness whatever exactly that
would entail
i feel the same way about it as i do
about um this the debate about sex ed
and you know for so long it was do we
have comprehensive sex ed education or
do we have abstinence education
well i think abstinence education if
you're gonna do it is is uh better than
the so-called comprehensive sex ed but
i'd prefer neither
how about just don't talk about it how
about you as a public school teacher you
don't need to have this kind of
conversation with my kids whether you're
talking about abstinence or not
i mean yeah it's the worst thing
is for public school teachers to be you
know telling kids about how to put on
condoms and that sort of thing
um that's obviously wildly inappropriate
but i also don't i don't really
i'm not going to entrust
a conversation about abstinence with
some random public school teacher either
it's an important message
but you can leave that to me to talk
about i don't want you to do it i don't
trust you to do it i don't trust you to
handle that subject and it's not
appropriate for you to be talking about
it
to kids who are not your own
so yeah you don't want you don't want to
kids to be taught about being straight
in sick when they're six years old sure
that's not i don't even know what that
would mean exactly and it's not
happening but i'm on board for that
just stick to the actual academic
subjects that are appropriate for their
age how about that for an idea
one other quick clip so um
a non-binary teacher has is speaking out
as so many others are
try to explain why uh it's so important
for
this person who i believe is a female
uh to be able to talk about this let's
listen
it makes me very angry when
people don't want to talk about gender
and sexuality in classrooms um
specifically for the reasons that
students won't understand
um
because in
my experience with teaching that
is never the case
i'm a non-binary teacher and i use the
title mix
and today i had 12 new students and i
just go
hi my name is mick smurfy q i use mix
instead of miss it's a little bit
different but i'm still a teacher just
the same
and they got it right away
i got mixed and sort of missed all day
um
and it makes
it it confuses me when people use that
excuse that children won't understand
because
students are very intelligent and
they're learning all day
it's not hard for them to learn a
different type of title
mix
how stupid does this get in a way it
kind of makes sense you know mix you are
pretty mixed up it sounds like
um
but no that's
the kids who went along with it that's
not them understanding
there's nothing to understand it's
nonsense
nobody at any age can understand the
concept of being non-binary because it's
incoherent and so it's impossible to
understand
for anyone it's not that they understand
it they just go along with it because
they're kids
and also because they probably even at a
young age i don't know how young her
kids are but sounds like they're pretty
young
um
her rather i should say her students the
kids in her class
uh no they they go along with it and no
matter how young they are
they've probably also already noticed
that they're in a social environment
where they have to just accept this kind
of thing
even if it occurred to them to ask
questions about it a lot of kids it
won't occur to them to ask questions
about it
they tend to just accept what whatever
reality is presented to them a lot of
adults do that too
kids especially
but even if they thought even if they
had questions about it or were unsure or
felt a little weird or strange um given
the social environment they're in they
would they would these kids are not
going to say that out loud
because of the consequences they would
face for it
social consequences and even actual
you know
penalties from their teachers
administrators
so
when you
tell a bunch of nonsense to a kid
and they sit there with a blank
expression and kind of nod their heads
and say okay
that's not them understanding
that's them cooperating
um that's them being brainwashed perhaps
because it's not hard to do with little
kids
but no that's that is that's not what
understanding is
but this is yet another teacher who just
like the kindergarten teacher we heard
from yesterday
um as far as they're concerned the kids
are there
to hear about
them these teachers think that this is
what it's all about this is what the
kids are there for to hear about them
and their own lives or their own
experiences
all right fox news has this story
says jose castillo a current walt disney
company employee who's running for
congress in florida as a republican told
fox news digital that the silent
majority of disney employees support the
parental rights law
despite the loud minority leading disney
to take a stance against the law which
critics have branded the don't say gay
bill um castillo said there's immense
pressure to tow the company line however
the reality is that those drawings
attached to this issue are in the
minority the disney cast members who
support the parental rights defended by
hp 1557 far outnumber those who are
protesting it
i am so tired of hearing about silent
majorities
i mean it it's probably true
i would guess
that most i mean disney has tens of
thousands of employees and it's probably
true spread all across the globe
and so it's probably true that the
majority of them
agree that we shouldn't be talking to
seven-year-olds about their sexuality
but i'm so sick of hearing about the
silent majority
it honestly makes me sick
it makes me even more sick when
conservatives take solace in it
and are kind of like proud of it and say
you see the silent majority agrees with
us
why are you being silent
that makes it worse not better
i would rather when you look at what's
happening with disney i would rather
think i would rather believe
that 90 of disney employees are as
insane as the these lgbt activists that
are pushing disney in this direction i'd
rather think that you know 90 of them
all of them are on board with it
that would be less frustrating to me and
also even slightly less concerning
than what we're hearing about here
that this is just a small sliver of the
company a small minority
everybody else knows that it's crazy and
they're not saying anything about it
i don't hear about silent majorities
anymore
because if you're in the majority and
you're being silent then it's we're not
we're not on the same if we're on the
same side but you're silent then we're
not actually on the same side
um
you are on the other side giving your
affirmation through your silence
that's what's happening i don't want to
hear about silent majorities
look i get it if you speak up and you're
at disney
if you're the only one to speak up then
they're just gonna they're gonna throw
your ass out you're done you're going to
get fired understand that
now
if 80 or whatever of disney employees
don't agree with this and all of them or
even a a good portion of them speak out
well they can't fire everybody
but even then it's still you're still
put you're still putting something on
the line it's still a risk
even if you all speak up as a group so
either way i totally understand
this part of it that if you speak up you
face consequences you speak up at your
job you face constantly you could lose
your job
that's no small thing you got kids to
feed i get it
i understand generally in society it's
the same deal
you speak up you face you you could face
serious penalties for it
just like i understand the
uh women on these sports teams where men
are invading if they
really protested vocally
put their name and face on that protest
not just doing it anonymously
they face serious consequences but at a
certain point
you you have to be willing to put
something on the line
i mean
our
what's at stake here is our is our whole
society
is at stake
are we going to just careen
at full speed into total madness and
leave
that kind of
world for our kids
is this is this the world we're going to
leave for them
because we're afraid to say anything and
we don't want to lose our job
and so we stay silent and just watch as
as our whole civilization marches off a
cliff
and everything is splintered and broken
on the jagged rocks below and then we
you know our time on earth is done and
we say to our kids okay well have fun
with this
help you figure this one out
is that what we're going to do
or are we going to speak up now and say
something
yeah one of the excuses people have now
for not speaking up and not saying
something and i imagine a lot of the
employees of disney the silent majority
one of the reasons they would give if
you were to ask them why they're not
saying anything is well i've got kids
and if i lose my job it's gonna make it
harder to care for my kids and i get it
but
if you don't speak up
then yeah you'll be able to
take care of your kids financially a
little bit a little bit easier
but you've made it a lot harder so you
made your kids you may if you don't
speak up then your kids lives right now
will be easier but
their lives in the future
based on the culture and society that
we're giving them it's gonna be it's
gonna be a lot harder because of your
silence
so i'm tired of the excuses
sometimes courage is called for in life
and this is one of those times
you know you gotta we gotta stand up and
do something speaking of which good
transition here the daily wire is um
is doing something uh when it comes to
uh many of these problems but especially
when it comes to the leftist activism
in um
in children's entertainment so it was
announced yesterday the guy king jeremy
boring held a town hall which was uh
which we live streamed and i guess we
have a clip of it we do okay so uh
jeremy's announcing our new initiative
here at diy we got so many things going
on it seems like every day we're
announcing a new thing but it's an
exciting time and so this is the the
latest venture of ours and let's listen
to that
because of the great reporting of chris
ruffo we got to see
leaked footage from inside disney
of high up disney employees saying
things like we have a not so secret gay
agenda
saying things like we insert we we uh
make sure i get this quote right
we're adding in queerness
wherever we can and that quote no one is
trying to stop
the producer who was doing so another
executive within the company said if
anything we don't have enough
lgbtqia representation
in content made for very small children
so what are we going to do about it
well we're going to do the same thing we
always do we're going to build
alternatives americans have enormous
economic might they just don't have any
alternatives the daily wire is building
those alternatives and today i'm proud
to tell you that we will be launching
daily wire kits our best days can be
ahead walt disney said we can accomplish
all of our dreams can come true
if we believe
that's what we're saying
we have to believe in that future i
don't think that the future that the
disney company is building today is the
future that walt disney
dreamed of
i think that it's the future that's
actually only being dreamed of by a tiny
segment
of
radicalized extreme left i don't think
that your average democrat wants their
kids having those values implicated in
them i don't think that
anyone in this country wants it except a
tiny minority
so let them spend all of their money
alienating everybody and we'll be over
here waiting we believe in our daily
wire audience we believe that they will
subscribe in fact
if you're watching right now and you're
not a dailywire.com subscriber
i'm asking you not for a donation
i'm asking you not begging i'm asking
you go buy something something of real
value go buy a membership to the daily
wire go buy a membership to jeremy's
razors
put your money
where your mouth is
come take part with us in building the
future in fact if you go to
dailywire.com build the future right now
you can become a dailywire.com member if
you want to because i know the price is
high if you want to save a little money
you could use promo code build the
future and we'll give you 45 off
or don't
because we need all the money that we
can get
what is it worth to you
what's it worth to you to have content
that you can trust your children with
what's it worth to you to have
entertainment that doesn't sucker punch
you every time you turn it on what's it
worth to you to have a good shave
without
believing that the company that's
selling you the razor wants to cut your
throat
figuratively
[Music]
so daily wire kids will be we're we're
putting a lot of money into this
investing it'll be will be officially
launched next year
but
yeah this is the time this is the time
to subscribe uh become a subscriber
help us in this this mission i mean i
know as a parent
even before all this stuff with disney
this is you talk to other parents it's
like one of the
the primary complaints that you have and
there's a lot of reasons to complain as
a parent in modern society
um
but this is what this is one of the main
things that you know it's you you want
to find just some entertainment for your
kids it's not that you want to
put your kid or at least you shouldn't
want to put your kid in front of a tv
all day and there are parents that do
that and they shouldn't but
um
why should it be so hard to find at
least some entertainment for your kids
that they can just watch
and it's and you can be confident
that there's not going to be not just
like little hints of liberalism here and
there
but far left activism in the
entertainment itself
and i know from experience just like any
other parent knows it's very hard you
cannot trust anything these days
you can't just put on any show and say
oh that'll be fine
up until
a year ago
you know eight or nine months ago you
might have thought you could do that
with a show like i don't know blues
clues
you would have thought blue's clues well
it's a show about a cartoon dog and he's
going around his house looking for a
stapler or something that's like the
whole episode
how could you possibly make that into
far left radicalism well
now you turn on blue's clues and you see
episodes with talking about with drag
queens singing about pansexuals
so that's how bad it's got and that's
why we've got the daily wire kids go to
dailywire.com and become a subscriber
today okay so from the daily wires well
it says a buffalo based lesbian couple
is suing cny fertility clinic
in new york for allegedly giving them
the wrong embryo
heather wilhelm rautenberg and robin
rottenberg wilhelm explicitly requested
that they have a baby daughter after
undergoing fertility treatments
however the couple was devastated to
find out that they were expecting a son
now they're responding with legal action
against the fertility clinic claiming
that heather became suicidal after her
son's birth and entered a dark
depression upon finding out that she was
carrying a baby boy
upon first finding out the child was
male at her 15-week appointment heather
said she became convinced the ivf clinic
mixed up the embryos she was actually
carrying somebody else's baby
heather told amy klein at the post i
looked at robbie and said what if it's
not yours who's in my body that's when i
flipped out that's when i felt my body
was taken hostage
um
continuing we scheduled an ultrasound
for the next day that was the worst
night of my life i had this overwhelming
sense of immobility i remember lying in
my bedroom thinking this can't be
happening not only was the baby in my
body not our not ours but the baby in my
body was male and he was put there
against my will just like rape
um and then it goes on i can't even
continue reading this entire thing it's
so disgusting
but
they you know gave birth to the to the
child
and now they're saying it's it's as if
she was raped so who
is the rapist in this analogy
the baby
i suppose that's what it's looked at how
it seemed now she says that this child
was putting my body against my will of
course that's not the case at all you
you very much chose to undergo this
procedure
and this is one of the consequences of
when we treat
human life like a commodity
and we treat conception like some sort
of science experiment that we do in a
petri dish
okay
this is one of the consequences and i
don't mean consequence of embryos could
get mixed up or whatever and you don't
get exactly what you ordered ordered i
mean that is one of the consequences but
just think about the way we're talking
about this
you ordered it like it's a catalog like
you ordered a you know jacket from l.l
bean or something this is human life
and the real consequence is that you
start to see human life as a commodity
and then what you get the wrong one
quote unquote and you want to return it
and you're suing because it was a you
know a mistake in the customer service
end of things
treating human life like a commodity
that's the consequence
and where it all becomes about you right
so for this lesbian couple
um the child is all about them
they're having this child
to serve their own emotional needs it's
not about the child
it's not about loving the child and
caring for the child it's about them
and they also believe
and this is another problem with
you know the surrogacy ivf all this
stuff
is that it carries with it this idea
that you have a right we talked about
this last week it's like this idea that
you have you have a right to a child
when in fact you don't
now if you have a child as a parent then
you have a right to care for your
children and to not have that superseded
by the government those are your
parental rights
but you don't have an underlying human
right to have a child to begin with
that's not a right that exists but
that's the way we see it now
and so these women thought well i have a
right i have a right to a child and then
i get i get quote the wrong one well my
rights have been infringed upon and so
now you have to pay me
so that's the consequence of treating
human life like it's a commodity it's
just one it's one of the more egregious
examples but we see it all the time in
our society now moving on um
to this
the will smith
slapped her around the world um
continues to draw reactions and it's
pretty clear now
that at least on
on the race hustling left you know the
the narrative is that um
he's entitled to respond that way
because
well because he's a
a black man in defense of of his wife
and so he's i guess entitled to
to to hit anybody that he wants to hit
and also what we're being told and
here's one viral video from someone
who's making this point that um if
you're a white person you really
shouldn't be talking about this at all
it's this it's not your place like will
smith can walk up on stage during the
oscars and physically assault someone
and he's entitled to do that but if
you're a white person you're not
entitled to even have an opinion about
it
at least that's what we're told listen
what happened at the oscars is not
something white people need to speak on
right away there is so much nuance and
complexity and layers that you will not
be able to understand through your white
experience without education and
listening to specifically black women
which we all know many people don't so
when you share your perspective or your
education on what you perceive to have
happened last night it's coming through
your white lens which has you on a place
of moral high ground black's
understanding of black trauma has such
an emphasis on this binary of who is
good or who is bad centers violence only
actually continues to minimize black
women and their pain and most annoyingly
continues to center yourself
that really just is not your business so
just take some time take a minute you
don't have to respond right away really
try and look at the entire situation
before you speak on the shiny easy grab
because what you failed to see through
your white lens was the actual violence
occurring the continued violence that is
ableism and that is misogynoir
oh okay
well yeah just just let us know whoever
you are when we're allowed to speak and
have an opinion about this event that
occurred and we all saw and everybody
was talking about just let us know uh
just just you know we'll we'll we'll all
shut up collectively and we'll wait for
you
whoever you are on tick tock
because we're the entitled ones right
we're the ones who are entitled i mean
she's just instructing an entire race of
people letting us know the opinions
we're allowed to have and not have but
we're entitled
and also we're trying to make it about
us not her she's not the one doing that
we're doing that if you're wondering
about this misogynoir
term
and it's a it's a new it's a new leftist
buzzword every day and this this seems
to be at least every week every week
there's a new one this is the leftist
buzz phrase of the week
and it's um i just looked it up because
that's not the first time i've heard it
this week misogynoir is according to
wikipedia
is misogyny directed towards black women
where race and gender both play roles in
bias
the term was coined by black feminist
moya bailey
in 2010 and now it's uh so it's that's
the other thing they do is like you take
this term that just some random leftist
came up with
and then um
and like two people have ever heard in
their lives and then they just start
like using it as if everyone is supposed
to know what this gibberish means
um but it's very effective because then
people do exactly what i just did there
you look it up like what is that what
does that mean okay
and then it enters into the lexicon so
um if if a black woman
is the subject of alleged sexism it's
not good enough to just say misogyny
like everybody else so she gets her
special label which is misogynoir
and all this this whole thing is very
nuanced the whole situation well it's
actually not nuanced at all it's like
it's probably one of the least
nuanced
public events
in recent memory
it was someone standing up at an awards
show and slapping another guy because
they didn't like a joke that was being
told there's no nuance to it whatsoever
very straightforward
all right this um quick follow-up from
the daily wire says representative
madison cawthorne
allegedly admitted to house minority
leader kevin mccarthy during a meeting
on wednesday that his claims that senior
lawmakers have used cocaine in front of
him and invited him to their homes for
orgies are not true he played the clip
yesterday of madison cawthorne on some
podcast
making a comparison to house of cards
and saying that real life dc is similar
to house of cards and claiming that he'd
actually been invited to orgies um
involving other members of congress only
uh he said that
he was invited the way he phrased the
two sexual get-togethers and that he
also had witnessed
other politicians using cocaine right in
front of him
and this led to outrage among
members of congress you might say they
protest a little bit too much
and um
and now they're saying uh mccarthy is
saying that he admitted that it was uh
that it was an exaggeration
um although he has not said that himself
here's what i'll say like i said
yesterday
it
it does not seem at all outlandish to me
that this kind of thing goes on i mean
we know it goes on
we had uh we had
like was talked about yesterday a member
of congress having threesomes
with her staff members
so we know this kind of thing goes on
drug use i'm sure it goes on
um
do they
invite each other to these events
that explicitly i don't know
so i don't know whether madison
catherine actually
you know encountered this or not but i
but i will say that
if you did encounter something like that
then you should name names
like i'm willing to believe that this
stuff goes on
but if you were if you know about it you
know who's doing it if you actually saw
a member of congress
you know do cocaine right in front of
you then tell us who
put names attached to it
that's the other thing i'm sick of along
with the silent majority i'm tired of
hearing these stories oh yeah the things
i've seen you wouldn't believe well tell
me about it
you've watched you've watched members of
congress break the law right in front of
you tell us who did it put their name on
it
if you're not going to do it then just
there's no point in bringing up to begin
with let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
all right we got one video comment of
somebody who
has actually dared to disagree with me i
believe and let's listen to him make his
argument
hi matt i respectfully disagree with you
on the point that you made regarding
that republicans
voted to pass the anti-lynching bill you
said they should have voted against it i
would say no
because if they voted against it they
would have given the democrats exactly
what they want so we know that democrats
are race hustlers they keep
making up
straw men regarding racism in the
country so that they give the american
people the impression that they are
the party that is fighting for a
quote-unquote racial justice so if
republicans didn't vote to pass the
antelope chamber they would have given
them exactly what they want they would
have given democrats
a huge ammo for years to come so
i'm glad they voted to pass it but at
the same time they should have pointed
out that it is a charade we are voting
for it but we know it's just a charade
but because we're always the party
that looks at people as equal human
beings that's what you
they they should have done
um
and sbg for life
um
well don't give me that at the end after
you've dared to contradict me on my own
show no i look i i
i completely disagree with you for one
thing they can't
they cannot vote for it and then say
we're voting for it but it's a charade
none of them did right i mean they just
voted for it didn't talk about it uh the
few members the few republicans who
called it a charade called it what it is
didn't vote for it and that's the way it
has to be if you're going to vote for
you can't also come out and say this is
all empty virtue signaling because then
that raises then the obvious
comeback is well why are you voting for
it then so you're voting for something
that you know that you acknowledge is an
empty charade you're wasting everyone's
time and you're voting for it anyway it
just makes you a coward you're just
you're you're amplifying your own
calories you're admitting to it if you
do that so either
you vote for it
and you say nothing
or you don't vote for it you explain why
those are the only two options that you
really have
and they chose the
path of least resistance the most
cowardly path as all as always and just
voted for it and yes i understand that's
the reason why the reason that you
outline is the reason why they voted for
it is because they didn't want the
headline oh republicans vote against
um
vote against anti-lynching law
but they're still going to be
subject to the racism charge regardless
this doesn't change that at all so it
really doesn't make a difference
and rather than just assuming
that the left is going to win the
narrative game ahead of time so you
don't even play rather than doing that
how about counteract the narrative
explain why
it can't just be a couple of republicans
but they all have to be on the same page
or at least most of them
and you flip it back around see that
you're assuming just like the
republicans do that they're going to
lose the narrative battle ahead of time
so they don't even bother
and it's not like this is only i mean it
is only empty virtue signaling but it's
not like it has a neutral effect
because
the point of passing this bill yeah it's
to give democrats a chance to virtue
signal it's to give joe biden a chance
to virtue signal but also
it's to send the message to give the
impression to the american people
that this kind of bill is number one
necessary and number two um
had not been passed in the past because
of racism
so all at once
they're sending they're they're
reaffirming this false narrative about
america's past and our present
because the impression they want to give
to people is that well we need an
anti-lynching law because people are
still getting lynched which isn't true
and also that this law was never it was
never
was never signed in the past because of
uh because of all the systemic racism
which is also not true
so it's not a neutral thing you go along
with it and you're also you're not just
going along with the bill itself you're
going along with the narrative
that is attached to it
i mean what's next
what if what if i mean next they're
gonna sign a law they're gonna have a
law
specifying that you're not allowed to i
don't know burn gay people at the stake
we need we need a specific law for that
even though that's already illegal
15 different ways to sunday we need a
specific law for that the anti-burning
gay people to stake law
you're gonna vote for that too
i mean let's just go through each
hypothetical violent act that could be
that horrible violent act that could be
committed and we need a federal law
specifically
against each of those things
where does it end should republicans go
along with that as well
no at a certain point how about just
going with the truth telling people the
truth
trusting people to understand it
all right let's see jared hyman says
little bit of fact checking things that
are falling do not continue to
accelerate indefinitely they eventually
reach terminal velocity which it does
seem like disney has now reached a lot
of a lot of comments correcting me on
the physics i knew i should not have
made an analogy that had to do with
physics but in fairness to me i never
said that things fall indefinitely and
or rather increase in velocity
indefinitely i just said big increase in
velocity then they hit the ground
whatever
but then i also i switched the i
switched the analogy and i was talking
about black holes
and what happens there i mean i imagine
your
velocity increases as you enter into the
black hole right or
we're just gonna we're gonna stop
i'm gonna i'm gonna quit while i'm
behind
um
dna studios says one thing about the
will smith thing is if it was real why
at the moment his hand slapped rock's
face there was a thud
now if you've ever slapped someone's
skin it doesn't sound like a thud
think about that one
i know it just it sounds like someone
getting slapped in the face just
why are you so desperate for this to be
a conspiracy there there are enough
actual real world conspiracies
we don't need this one
this this
is not only a dumb conspiracy theory but
it's the lamest one imaginable it's like
in
focus your energies elsewhere is what i
would say
um
all as grace says is someone who is who
has multiple rare diseases as well as a
mother of a young daughter who has the
same and has adhd this false diversity
and inclusion can be very irritating how
many disabled and or neurodiverse people
does disney include in their offerings
this is not coming from a victim
mentality mindset there are legitimate
diversities out there and our world
could be a much better place for all of
us if those who wanted to be inclusive
really were but alas it's not about that
it's about the agenda
i understand what you're saying i can't
i can't go along with you here i can't i
can't join you on this ride because
number one you're using the ridiculous
term neuro-diverse
um but also
how about this
um
just tell good stories
like have the characters in the stories
that need to be there in order for it to
be a compelling story
i don't think we need to counter the
leftist thing about diversity and
inclusion by saying oh you know what uh
no they actually don't have enough
diversity and inclusion we need even
more of it i don't think that's the
right response
it's just tell the story
we don't need to
have a chart where we're keeping track
okay do we have this identity
represented this identity that it no
just just tell the story that's all well
in a world of woke razors sold by men
who cave to the demands of social
justice warriors you can now use a razor
that pivots but doesn't cave and yes i'm
talking about the daily wire and our new
razor company jeremy's razors if you
aren't one of the 45 thousand americans
who already purchased jeremy's razors
subscriptions then head over to i hate
harry's dot com to get your founder's
kit and subscription now the launch of
our new razer company has been extremely
successful and because of this
tremendously positive response we're
actively working to expand the jeremy's
razors team in nashville tennessee
specifically jeremy's races is currently
looking for an executive president
rather executive vice president as well
as a director of consumer experience
this is a huge opportunity to not just
sell razors but to be on the front lines
of taking back the power from woke
corporations if you're interested head
to dailywire.com careers this is your
chance to join us now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today i'm pleased to cancel miss ayo
sakai
she describes herself as an author poet
political scientist and linguist
activist i can only assume she added
something as nonsensical and meaningless
as a linguist activist into her bio to
distract from how nonsensical and
meaningless the term political scientist
already is but in any case all these
titles are secondary to miss sakai as
she explained in a viral tweet
the most important thing that you should
know about her and the thing that you
really must know everyone must know it
um they must know it simply by looking
at her somehow most important detail is
that she has a phd so she posted it is
time to normalize the doctorate it is
not miss it's doctor it's not mrs mr sir
or ma'am it's doctor not only at
conferences seminars or academic spaces
it's at the grocery store the hospital
the church the airport children's
schools it's doctor exclamation point
okay chief whatever you say
now before we engage with this in more
detail we should note all of the other
whiny academics in the comments who
concurred for example margaret maloney
phd says i'm with you on this why should
i be made to feel like i'm being snotty
because i want to be called by my
official title and not miss or ma'am
then dr elizabeth craig agreed i
literally have a visceral reaction when
i'm in a setting that i should be called
doctor and i'm called miss or missus
dr sean helfian offered this
this aversion to using earned honorifics
from accredited institutions reveals
more the intellectual inferiority
complex of the people who refuse to
accept them than the justified
insistence of those who earn them
by the way dr sean is a plant ecologist
he spent seven years reading about
plants and he wants you to acknowledge
that fact every time you address him you
can't just say hey sean or hey you
self-important pompous little useless
goober which would be more accurate you
must say
dr shawn or doctor self-important
pompous little useless goober
whatever you say sean needs you to make
verbal notes of all of the ecology
textbooks he read
of course even if you're the sort of
person who would be inclined to stroke
the ego of fragile narcissistic alleged
intellectuals like these
you may still be confused as to how
you're supposed to know that they have
these academic credentials
sakai wants you to call her doctor at
the grocery store well is she wearing
her cap and gown to the grocery store
does she rock a walk-around with a
sandwich board sign with a resume
written on it
actually if she did the sign would be
blank because she has no resume
none of these people do anything or have
any discernable skills
the point is just that the doctorate is
not public knowledge unless you spread
word about your doctorate through a
media pr campaign a la jill biden
most people simply aren't going to know
otherwise and if they do know who cares
why should they have to address you
accordingly
i'm unlikely to call even a medical
doctor doctor outside of a medical
context
the funny thing though is that most
medical doctors i know don't insist on
being called doctor the doctors who seem
hell-bent on being called doctors are
the fake doctors like the ones in this
twitter thread and the one married to
the president
you can at least
see why it might be useful to identify
and acknowledge medical doctors in
everyday life
situations can arise where a doctor
might be needed
so you know it's there's there's that
reason although it's a practical reason
why maybe it's not nice to know who the
doctors are but it's hard to imagine an
emergency that would require a plant
ecologist
as essential and necessary as io sakai
might see yourself i doubt there's ever
been a time when somebody rushed into a
room and shouted help uh we need a
political scientist hurry
also a link a linguist activist would be
helpful as well we get both
but this is all part of the narcissism
of the age i think there's a reason why
people who put titles in front of their
names and letters after them are also
prone to listing their pronouns it's the
same sort of thing people are constantly
seeking to be affirmed acknowledged you
know because they're they're empty
inside they're obsessed with identity
but the identity is exactly what they
lack ironically
they're not grounded in anything they're
rootless and hollow they're addicted to
acknowledgement they're desperate for
affirmation
i remember a there was a this weird and
pretty bad horror movie that i watched
several years ago
i forget what it was called but there's
the sudden darkness that falls over the
country and
people disappear into the darkness and
essentially like dematerialize like i
said it's weird but as each character
disappears into the abyss they start
muttering i exist i exist over and over
again as they try helplessly to reassert
their own existence
i think something similar is happening
in our culture today
people feel as though they're constantly
on the verge of non-existence and they
depend on everybody else on every
passing stranger on the street to affirm
them
to like hold them in existence
they seem to fear that if they're not
acknowledged in exactly the way they
want to be acknowledged they'll
disappear
in fact you often hear people
like this complain about being erased
and i think that fear is perhaps more
literal than we realize
people who spend hundreds of thousands
of dollars and years of their lives just
to earn a title that they can put on
their names and
um you know they they are often going to
be the most desperate for this kind of
affirmation that's precisely why they
went through all of that effort to begin
with
and i say all of this as a scholar of
women's studies myself
even though i'm a best-selling women's
studies author of the book what is a
woman available for pre-order at
whatiswoman.com which is based on the
film which will soon be released you can
also watch the teaser what is one.com in
spite of all that
um and of the fact that my status as the
nation's pre-eminent women's studies
expert and lgbt children's author
essentially makes me a doctor as well
i still do not insist on having those
achievements recognized all the time
i just want to recognize most of the
time
well all the time i guess but i'm the
exception
as for the rest of these fake doctors
desperate for attention and for
affirmation
they are all today of course canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
new polls show democrats getting
destroyed in november germany outlaws
expressing support for russia and an
american university gets rid of its
diversity equity and inclusion office
great stuff check it out at the michael
knowles show